[موسيقى]
الذي وصفته قبل قليل نحن نعتقد ان
المتقدمون جدا وليس من الضروري ان نبذل
الجهد او ان استثمر والسبب الاخر
وانا لا اتحدث المتحده بل الاستخبارات
الغربيه بشكل عام كلها منحازه تجاهها
المعلومات السريه
ويجمع المعلومات مصادر المفتوحه ويحللونها
ولكن هي اقل نسبيا ولا اخذها على نفس
الجديه كما ياخذون المعلومات السريه
وبالتالي او نتيجه لذلك فهناك ميزانيات
اقل واراده اضعف
لوضعه البرامج الخاص بمراقبه المسار
المفتوحه حاليا تكنولوجيا الاجنبيه هذا
شيء لم يفعله من قبل
[موسيقى]
قبل عامين في عام 2021
نشر قائمه 18 نقطه من الاشعه يمكن نقوم
بها
للتحقيق الدوليه من دون استئنافي استنزافي
التكنولوجيا الخاصه هنا في الولايات
المتحده هذه القائمه في حد ذاتها كانت
منقحه من قائمه ب 30 نقطه وكانت سريه صدرت
قبل ثلاثه
اعوام او ثلاثه اعوام قبل 20 واحد وعشرين
الاهداف
الافكار موجوده
ولكن لا توجد اي اراده او رهبه بتطبيقها
ليس الى الان على الاقل اعتقد بان العنصر
الاهم بين كل نقاط التي تحدثنا عنها هي ان
الولايات المتحده والدول الاخرى
يجب ان توضح ما هي القواعد الدوليه وما هو
مقبول وما هو غير مقبول اقصد من السلوكيات
وليس على جميعا يخمنه في هذه المرحله يجب
ان يكون واضحين تماما
[موسيقى]